siege has now been around for long
enough that it's starting to usher in a
second if not third generation of
superstars we've gone from
sailor-mouthed strategists and avian
smg-11 savants to sweet humble as hell
youtubers and four adoring frenchmen
with aim that'll make your legs shake
good little quick peek but no shots
connected baby good night and while it
is true that certain crazed canucks and
chaota crying demons are still going
strong
a new era of household names have
started to cement themselves in their
prime prodigies who were young enough
when siege came out that they were
raised by it born in it it's only up to
rampi now he's gonna be able to go for a
clutch as well for an ace clutch even he
gets two to start it off that's a
potential third but dan survives just
barely it's the third one to come
through he spots one more he's gonna be
able to get that one he swings around
the corner he gets a little bit out no
way he gets a quad kill that is the
second clutch in a row what are we
seeing right here emmy but what if i
told you that siege's newest breakout
star
sort of came out of nowhere that the
name on everyone's lips right now wasn't
some electric challenger league offering
or european bolo to be but instead a
belligerent loudmouthed
batman wannabe what
[Music]
[Music]
i'm vengeance
today i'm here to evangelize you all
about david iconic iphone
the suave sightstormer who against every
odd became the newest fiercest face of
the nal
[Music]
and it's in the favor of really no one
right now but astralis takes the cake
after everything settles marm now alone
she's been in these clutches before but
this one's going to be asking a bit too
much bro
that's all dude i had the wrap on that
ball where you didn't know where i was
so where did iconic's siege journey
begin how did being benched barely
avoiding relegation and embracing an
oppressive meta result in him topping
the league whilst donning one of the
most elite jerseys in esports and in
what sense has our boy gone from the
[ __ ]
to the stars
is it shot in midair because it doesn't
go off iconic picks up kill number three
kill number four and he gets them oh
iconic with the ace
all right so before we start talking
about king iconic i must ask that you
lovely siege heads like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications also be sure to check out
our newest interview series unmuted our
last episode saw yours truly sit down
with the boy bolo we ran some ranked
unranked talked all things siege and
laughed as some of his fanboys went
insane wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait so
tell me tell me tell me please
are you real please
please be real bro please oh what's good
oh my god
okay so in order to understand how
iconic went from a scrappy up-and-comer
to a world-class entry fragger with the
swagger of an nba superstar
we need to talk about where he came from
like many of mr clancy's nastiest
disciples iconic actually got his start
on console where he showed early signs
of promise and then around skull rain i
got into the game uh more seriously i
just played it more and more on xbox i
actually like really fell in love with
the game and then that obviously
made me want to get a pc to switch to pc
then i switched to pc at the end of
chimera so like those are like that's
like the seasonal
time window the second he switched to pc
iconic began leveling up his game at an
almost inhuman rate this guy was truly
willing to do whatever it took to be the
best i was just doing everything
possible i was watching
youtube videos from like a whole bunch
of different uh creators at the time
just to learn the game better and i
would just like i would just keep
evolving into that next level of like
okay i'm gonna learn from these content
creators sorry i'm gonna learn from
these pro players and i just kept
getting better and better at the game in
just under a year iconic went from
cutting his teeth and ranked and faced
at ten man's to duking it out alongside
other aspiring up-and-comers in the
cyber athlete championship series
siege's most reputable and influential
amateur league one will drop the hatch
he'll find one but he's got a lot more
to find he'll find two actually but
iconic will finally shut him down
part of the reason for iconic's meteoric
rise
was his attitude you see iconic wasn't
your average everyday grinder mentality
ranked demon who quit competitive every
three weeks via twitlander he was a
hard-nosed hard in the paint competitor
literally like it was just it was just a
new grind because i played basketball
for like all my life
before gaming and then
i kind of got hooked on gaming and i
just wanted to make it but rudy just
keeps getting frag after frag iconic
rushes straight through some gunfire
takes down one takes down two 1v1 why
are you picking him up iconic is pushing
yeah when i told my parents that i
wanted to quit basketball and uh like
just switch to gaming i was i told him i
was on xbox and i was like i feel like i
could go pro they trusted me with that
but the other reason iconic stood out
was his play style
let's just say that our boy was a bit of
a
w warrior at times he could be the
scariest ashmane alive
very dangerous position there for mort
he's going to get chased out i kind of
get another one lags will get one so
will brady just like that two minutes in
it's a 5v1 only one left a long angle
for the maestro oh nothing he could do
about it iconic drops three big ones i'm
just i'm just a chaotic player that's
all it is
other times
well
but actually iconic is going to rush
straight through anthony guns them down
how the pro shot i made that time
some of them thought i was a [ __ ]
i wasn't that smart of a player
uh
but
i i really don't care anymore like about
what they think but it was actually that
very unpredictable explosivity that made
iconic such a highly touted prospect so
by the summer of 2020 just two years
after switching off of console his dream
of competing professionally became a
reality i got the spot for sonics
like right before my birthday
and basically then i was like already
enrolled in college that fall so
basically i just deferred that semester
and i just went to harrisburg a few days
after graduation and just got after it
begs himself in alphama nice rotate
underneath by iconic takes down grixer
trying to push up white stairs now it's
all down to call out with that g8 can't
even win out that fight though iconics
all over that kill feed an iconic's uh
a pretty smart player in terms of
identifying like opportunities and not
being afraid to push it whether you fail
or succeed it's better to try something
and you know lose a gunfight or die that
way than it is to just
sit there and wait for something to
happen unfortunately despite performing
quite well individually iconic's stint
with the sonics came to an abrupt and
rather publicized end after he and three
of his teammates were benched after only
six months it's just an opportunity to
kind of get my name out there
and just kind of
sink my feet in the water and play pro
league for the first time what it showed
me in like my career-wise is how
important it is to have a team around
each other who just who can be with each
other inside and out of game and on that
team it was just a lot of internal
issues it just like it just kind of
exploded what iconic wanted was a roster
that was cohesive enough to complement
not only his chaotic play style but his
commitment to becoming a world-class
competitor thankfully he had just the
lineup in mind it was just mainly me
just going i wanted to go to dg just
kind of joined a team that uh i knew
that like i could enjoy the environment
and i could push us to be better i just
felt like i could really go there and
bring what they needed to help them like
just like like achieve more
joining disrupt in march of 2021 felt
like a homecoming for iconic this was
the type of roster he'd always
envisioned himself playing with one that
would enable him to express himself as a
player both in official matches and in
the so-called
shits
oh
nice
you see iconic was a hectic instinctual
fragger one who thrived on being in the
throes of battle you know they've got
him trapped in the bathroom we get
flashed out there's a deployable shield
behind him all the flashbangs landing a
great pivot from cairns and can he make
a miracle work from the spot he's got
some access to the diffuser he'll be
starting out of his mind and he's got
the follow-up but iconic is better that
was almost possible for kansan to pull
off but it's just a little bit
too late iconic pushing dirt iconic
pushing dirt right now
once one's underneath underneath on bomb
underneath that yeah that's that okay
okay dad
i'm gonna stop
oh my god
i mean i feel like being in the [ __ ] is
just
it's just fun there's not really any
thinking you're just kind of like you're
just kind of like just reacting off what
you see
i mean so it's just a fun way to play
siege that's all it is really
unfortunately in spite of disrupts very
promising start their results steadily
worsened over the course of 2021's three
stages
stage two
wasn't too bad we were it was mainly the
last game against sonics we just kind of
we lost that
to make the major
it was kind of like a blow that the team
never really recovered from super pops
up outdoored by retro kings and firing
away he's taken down it'll need to be
rexen to play a hero and he's getting a
ping he sees but can he get the position
yes he can and the sonics will get their
spot at the mexico major
they take it seven four going into stage
three it was just like we just weren't
working nearly as hard enough as we
needed to like after that season the s-i
calls it was just like it was kind of
like just like the end of the team in a
way like we just we just weren't working
it didn't help that going into stage
three disrupted undergone an extremely
awesome but sort of ill-timed astralis
rebrand here you had one of the most
respected and prestigious jerseys in
european esports being dawned by a group
of north american miscreants who were
fighting to not get relegated they get
this huge org this stage coming under
this huge mantle and it's basically just
fizzled out all of the hype behind them
i mean like the hype is still there per
se but like it's not as bold as it once
was obviously like you could say it came
at a bad time but everything happens for
a reason you know we had to go through
that just to kind of learn career
experience all that type of stuff so i
mean it was a bad time but it was a good
time at the same time going into 2022
it had become abundantly clear that
something had to change for astralis
resetting the culture of the team was
important so with that in mind the org
brought in call out as their new coach
alongside forest as their fifth our
whole thing which is to work as hard as
we could work and like the results to
speak for themselves and sweet baby
jesus
did they ever come the very first day of
the next stage astralis were decimating
the competition
and iconic
this dude could not be contained he's
sitting pretty right now all he has to
do is wait he's got some oh he's got a
free swing and he's got the clutch in
the map win for australis day after day
dub after dub astralis started cementing
themselves as the nal's unlikeliest
juggernaut and iconic
its newest nuttiest superstar miss nade
almost claims the ace of dp fire and
could have claimed to selma as well
there goes the adrenal surge and the
finger walks right in down goes spirits
and there's more as iconic continues to
fire away how do you even combat that is
it shot in mid-air because it doesn't go
off iconic picks up kill number three
kill number four and he gets the ball
iconic with the ace iconic currently
held back on whites there's a little bit
too close to it as well that could hurt
him in the long run that's another
bullet he can't take inside of this
fight suddenly benji is going way down
the field in the meanwhile here as he's
outside big window but iconic might
realize that he's going to force the
issue does bench oh
okay he survives the nade and iconic
with a massive clutch there taking off
his head in the server he was an
absurdly aggressive entry whose balls to
the wall's playmaking bordered on
belligerence
outside of it he was tweeting out nba
style fit pics and cryptic batman memes
confirming that he was becoming one of
the game's biggest personalities
sunglasses going on the you know during
the game too you know what what's the
edge there do you feel like there there
is an edge the sunglasses just it's just
we're just about fashion on this team
that's it
hello
i've been looking forward
you ain't me bro it's just it's just
meme to me all of this i just uh
i saw the batman trailer i really liked
it and then i was like me and henry are
supposed to meet the manager like
i'm like bro i need a nickname
and and he was like
make one and i'm like bro i'm the bat
batman was just like the perfect perfect
thing for me because it's like i'm not a
hero but i'm not like a villain either
i'm just on my vigilante arc now part of
the reason for astralis sudden
unstoppable explosivity was of course
their infrastructural overhaul but the
other reason was how dynamic they were
you see while everybody else was
let's say demoralized about lmgs and
decreeing attacker repic to be the
demise of competitive siege
astralis were using an admittedly
oppressive meta to their advantage
they weren't just playing the hand they
were dealt they were doubling down on it
the main thing is attack a re-pick
just it adds like just like a different
level of like creativeness to the game
just how how well and how fast you can
adjust lineups like round by round but
the lmg meta it's just like i don't
control the meta we're in like if the
lmg is the best gun for like that entry
up like i'm just using it like the
question come the charlotte major was
how astralis and specifically iconic
would fare internationally
there is a lot of questions iconic is
just playing with fire he also is wildly
inconsistent the answer
well
you tell me
j95 won't make it a second as well
they've found the kills they need but
rafael pulls two back but can they shut
him down here sat inside of bleepers c4
over the top defusers on the ground and
15 seconds to play j90 makes it three a
four versus two it's monty and the
shocker against the world it's not
looking good i caught it with the 3k is
down forest with the close be
it felt as if other more seasoned
rosters were still accustomed to this
rigid methodical step-by-step style of
siege and that astralis wildness was
just too synergistic to be stopped they
didn't just play off of calls they
played off of each other better than any
roster in the world that's a nice nade
that'll go on down and it connects on to
rise astralis start off the killing that
is exceptional for their fans again
you have almost 100 chance of winning if
you get the very first pick here's
another four iconic our style is
probably a bit uh
like it
it takes a bit getting used to so
probably had a bit of shock affect the
european teams we played throughout our
groups i mean we just we came in we
didn't really look at it like we're
playing
international like we didn't say it's
gonna be like a completely different
game just kind of came in like it was
gonna be like just just a regular game
of siege
and it's up to bibu but how about
another
flawless round for astralis oh my god
people i can't even get you right now
but i'm looking at you
i'm looking at y'all
by the time they reached the grand
finals it had become resoundingly clear
that whatever happened in this next
best-of-five barn burner
this roster was the real deal shuttle
knows this bad target prioritization the
yeager peaks pan bazook goes down
shuttle with the 4k all he needs is
hyper to complete the ace and send
astralis away with the win diffuser in
the hands of dp fire shuttle will need
to watch where will they come from hyper
now peaks on the other side of the bomb
site he's got the clock working against
him
through dorms but it's a game of keep
away they've dropped in and now he'll be
vulnerable as he goes with the future
and it's an easy finish with iconics
nitro cell
gun at close range let him go in iconic
be patient be patient what are you gonna
do you know two are there and he gets
some both there's only one remaining and
astralis are in good shape and jr and
god more k from iconic
batman's showing up
saved they saved the round
in spite of falling short with a second
place finish astralis bullied their way
onto siege's international stage and
proved that their fast-paced guns up
philosophy for [ __ ] on people was
truly first-rate i just want to say
though that they're an incredible team
they just made this roster they just
head for us and call it come in and
already they're making incredible
strides
they're truly a world-class team
and it was a pleasure to play against
them
as for iconic he showed everyone that he
was more than just a console kid with a
dream not only is he re-injecting life
back into the nal in a big way he's
ushering in a new era of siege superstar
one who values style
as much as substance if not a little
more sometimes
i always think that i'm the best player
in the lobby no matter who i'm playing
just not really much to it he drops
peaking
kind of like i don't know it was really
hard like these kids were going so
insane that it was like pretty hard i
think for him to like
not engage like he was very nice he was
extremely kind to them he was really
cool he was just he's such a nice guy
right like he was so so cool but like
these kids were going
bonkers like actually bonkers like
screaming at each other like oh my god
it's bob and they were actually like